emily is with us emily is in boulder
colorado hi emily how are you
hi good how's it going better than i
deserve what's up
so i have a couple questions i'm
actually headed to
sell my car right now so i'm going to
try to make it as quick as i can
maybe get to the second one but the
first one
sorry my voice is shaking so much
the first question is my boyfriend and i
were currently living in his mother's
basement
and we are we were planning
to have enough money saved up to be able
to move into an apartment
in july however with the
relationship to his mother she's now
wanting us out sooner
um she's generously offered to pay for
us
to do so but um
because of the relationship dynamic uh
i'm just a little unsure whether or not
to take her up on her offer so one
option
is for her to just pay the first couple
months rent
and the other option that she suggested
was to
for her to buy a property
and us to essentially pay the mortgage
or to
basically rent to own
okay um
how old are you i am 30 and my boyfriend
is 27.
okay so you're my kid's age
um and so
i'm gonna pretend like um you and i know
each other better than we do
and that i care deeply about your future
okay and um
uh because i do actually care deeply
about your future but we don't you and i
don't know each other that well
you've listened to me on the radio and
i've talked to you for a minute and a
half
all the time but um we listen to you
every day religiously
yeah and so if you've listened a lot
you probably have come across the call
where i tell people not to buy
properties or rent properties
with people they're not married to have
you heard that before
yes so it would not come as a surprise
to you that i would suggest to you that
this is ludicrous
it's about it it's a bad idea the one
where the one where she buys a house
and and wants you to be involved in
buying it with her son and you're not
married to him
is like about one of the craziest
dumbest things you could possibly ever
sign up for please
god don't do that okay
okay there's so many things wrong in
this transaction
legally relationally financially
yeah there's just there's this is all
dumb
please don't do that and these are good
people
trying to do a good thing a bad way
sure so um
yeah i is if she wants her son
to move out of her basement uh and she
wants to help him get an apartment is
she just going to give him some money to
do that
yeah she's um i haven't been involved in
any other conversations but basically
what i've
what i understand is that she has a
certain amount of money that she was
willing to give us for an apartment
uh we did find one but we
were going over the lease agreement and
just
realized that it was a really bad
decision uh there was
like pretty much all the liability was
on us so we backed out of it last minute
which is now why they are both
considering
this other option
you just didn't find an apartment yet
and you know okay here's what i would
suggest you do
okay and and i i
i know i'm asking a
real hard turn from where you guys plans
are so i don't know how successful i'll
be and what i'm asking
but my motivation is pure and my
uh experience is um 30 years of talking
to people like you
okay so he should go get an apartment
in his name period
and if his mommy wants to give him some
money to get out of her basement
that's between him and her you should
not be on the lease
with someone that you're not married to
and you certainly shouldn't be in a rent
to own
with someone you're not married to yeah
if you choose to shack up with him and
move in
to his apartment that the lease is in
his name
that's certainly your choice i would
recommend against that but i doubt i'm
gonna get that far
if i can get if i can get you far enough
that you're at least not signed on
documents with the guy you're not
married to
uh we're at least making some headway
for protecting you
okay because if y'all break up no let me
try this
when you break up
and you're both on the lease you know
how hard
this is going to be legally because the
apartment complex is not going to let
either one of you off
somebody's going to be in there not
paying it and the other one's getting
screwed
yep please don't be on a lease with
someone you're not married to
please do not buy a house from his
mother
on a blind to own with someone you're
not married to
you set yourself up legally not only
relationally
and we can talk about morally and
spiritually if you want to but i mean
all of these other things you're just
setting yourself up for all kinds of
problems honey
and i just i want you to win
yeah it was a little scary to to me but
i just wanted to
hear that from somebody else because
we've been getting conflicting advice
from
his parents and my parents and i know
ultimately it doesn't matter
does what i'm saying makes sense to you
yeah it no it definitely does okay i'll
just add this very quickly
dave gave you a really great dad
perspective and and i'm just gonna tell
you
if if i had your boyfriend on the line
you've mentioned
twice that there's some tension i'm just
that's me kind of pulling that out but
there's a relationship issue already
between
him and his mother i wouldn't take the
mom's money he needs to be a big boy
he's 27
put his big boy pants on and he needs to
go get an apartment and i'll tell you
what else if i had him on the line
he needs to commit to you i think dave
they've said it
very well i'm not adding two i'm simply
saying
i wouldn't i wouldn't enter into any of
this unless you're unless you know this
guy's committed to you
you guys are playing house right now
you're 30 years old
i don't know dave i just wouldn't take
the money from the mom it feels like
that could be
if there's an unhealthy relationship
with my mom or my dad i don't want to
take money from him
you're talking to him i would tell him
that that's what i'm saying i'm talking
to her right now i'm just trying to get
her away for this
oh i agree um you know illegally away
from it into a lease with this crazy
situation dangerous
so um but yeah i mean
and emily you just gotta understand i
mean ken and i are uh we're considered
old-fashioned dinosaurs
in our in our viewpoints on these things
but and i so i'm
only coming at you from the legal
perspective that you're going to get
trapped into a lease
when his mom blows your relationship up
and you'll be trapped in a lease with
mama's boy
and um or um or a young man that's at
war with his mother
who's a control freak i don't know
what's about to come up but they're this
is not gonna go well
this is not gonna you know they're
they're they're having this is
this is there's issues here and so
please please please give yourself
uh escape routes uh
don't don't chain yourself to someone
that you're not married to
this is your roommate argue over
whose mustard it is don't argue over
things that are going to bankrupt you or
put you into a situation that takes you
five years to recover from this landlord
suing you because the two of you broke
up and both of you moved out and nobody
paid the rent and you ended up paying it
because he disappeared
and his mommy's money with him and so
this is just danger danger danger danger
red flags all over the place
and that's what i would tell my daughter
except i would take it a step or two
further than i did with you
in terms of other paradigms through
which we would look at it as well
that we just ran out of time and can't
get to
but please don't do this